stream or maybe you watch the later
recording on YouTube that can also
happen of course yeah so here I am again
playing a little bit on leech s yeah I
have later today I'm going to click on
that there is the titled Rena the leech
has titled arena it is extremely strong
a bullet tournament it's going to start
at 10:00 p.m. Central European Time we
see like from here it's 5 hours 44 I
actually forgot something
I just forgot to switch on the twitch
site in the first place so that yeah
let's do that okay so which TV where's
my own stream should probably mute that
waste my own stream like here right I
definitely wanted shed where's the chat
here's the chit
sorry for all that I should have
prepared that so we have that I have the
chat window and now I can actually go to
play some games
yeah and later again I'm going to stream
this this tournament and yeah it's going
to be very strong I'm not totally sure
everybody is here yeah I mean but it's a
penguin gem you probably will know
entertain and yeah very strong
maybe Magnus will joined we don't know
he won the first prize tournament there
I know I'm not going to win any of those
heat prizes but yeah okay so let's see
is there a tournament going on or what
am I going to do I just fired up the
stream and didn't really think about it
that much before there is an hourly
super blitz and our body blitz yeah only
super blitz is there Wow 19 points so
that's very late you're not going to a
top 5 get prices you know what I'm just
going to I'm just going to going to get
some experience here with one minute and
I'm just going to play some bullet games
I have to play bullet later Enterprise
tournament so let's see if I get some
some bullet games using in the Ottawa
pairing system BB over 600k a very
aggressive here they're not super happy
here this have a good position but I
can't you have to play the hand you're
dealt
ok I think clicking here isn't so bad
got some good bishops with 94 would have
been quite awkward so not happy not
happy him
I'm just worse in this position even
though is helping me a little bit with
this play so things were even worse at
some point but come on didn't want to
play King edge - it's kind of silly
yeah training for the tight arena
drunken lawyer says and rightly so they
have to do some practice keeping this
hours and I mean I'm very active here I
don't know if I'm worried actually
Bishop age 6
you know I don't know if that works this
looks good I don't know I love if you
can take on c4 but the problem is that
yeah senior move him
just going to recapture this night is
completely dominated ok so that dead
worked out let's let's play a couple of
more with this guy if he if he goes up
for it yeah I cannot go Bishop c5 so
easily against this let's take them and
just be be solid yeah and I'm happy
about that is a very nice position now
God could play against see for him
I'm very happy with the Queensway to
face up to it oh he wants to trade I'm
not sure if one wants to trade but he
did
oh now I see four looks like it should
fall how is he not losing this he hasn't
earned I could have chicken d5 there was
a bit silly it was a bit silly and now
I've got a huge a huge fork here yeah I
missed some stuff but the position is so
pretty strong so weird opening he loses
lots of time there yeah I can take here
attacking b7 which she is ignoring have
a look here I got this chick here first
maybe Luke Luke a3 looks strong yeah
that's very strong actually mmm no mate
and that did I played really badly that
was really terrible actually I mean this
is probably so winning but I could have
done something stronger that is like
100% certain that there was a stronger
option
see five Queen takes BHS kind of cause
he still doesn't have the rook in the
game so no not trading Queens I need I
need marouk ruby one yeah it's just
pretty terrible but and I thought of
yeah I thought night on if I was saying
it could have taken a night yeah yeah
and maybe sometimes in the bullet games
I'm just I'm just firing oh that's a
weird transposition to a pond Sione
opening pepper should be happy could
have played anyway but we had ever
thought yeah but okay I can't count so
long shot not blunder the noid okay oh
yeah maybe here that looks kind of okay
I've I've played in somewhat slowly our
thanks for the nice feedback on my
name's iboga book
I'm really happy with with the quality
of the book to be honest there was lots
of work but I think it paid off in the
end a deficit so it's a really good it
is a good quality book I really think it
is
okay so let's push the prawns
they just metamour that they are then
advanced compared to the phone count
you know they just promote I think meat
okay so things things go oops
hey things go okay here going for the
Queen pawn opening oh no no London it's
not blunder this and maybe it's got a
four in this position home I can go here
yeah the storm is quite harsh yeah it
really is we have a pretty strong storm
here in in my area and I mean it's it's
probably a piece of cake to what people
experience like when they have
hurricanes in the US or something but it
is pretty it is pretty um it's pretty
strong earlier today I was out just just
for a brief period of time to to buy
some tea actually hit and it was I mean
it was pretty pretty awful so I'm
attacking the Queen here and I don't
know where it is supposed to go on I'm
taking a 6 was chick what's happening
yeah and this is also quite annoying I
can take each sex no all looks good
thank you yeah I mean in western in the
western part of Germany North
rhine-westphalia we never talked wisdom
okay so oh I don't have any time crap
yeah I was enjoying the position so much
I didn't really pay attention to the
time situation but unfortunately
fortunately it's going to be a quick
made and guys getting some sort of a
beating here okay really okay yeah I
like this position it looks like I'm
just a bit better and it was it was a
bit superficial here this move okay like
grip on let's grab the pawn I had a
brief disconnection from riches I hope
my connection is steady in general my
internet connection was a bit flaky last
weeks and the the storm dam probably
does not help all that much so what they
want to do here b5 at some point could
be an idea but I don't know when exactly
so I'm going to go back here to attack
the pin where I'm actually ahead in the
porn count yeah I need this it's a check
so will it see King f6 chicky always
good to check with the king but going
from here it's not so easy I don't quite
see how maybe b5 and then take on yeah
let's do it
take here it's still not easy for me to
play this pollution may overtake here
going to win on time okay let's see I'm
going to stop like after 10 games unless
he's leaving earlier how he he'd left
yeah okay so let's see if I can get a
new opponent going that was storm 100
okay okay
speak of the devil let's say let's go
here I know I don't play play the 15 or
what is that 15 second bullet hyperbola
don't I don't play that I have some
connection things going on connection
issues I hope it stays steady okay it's
too cute thank you get some good squeeze
not-so-nice actually Bishop to g5 would
be a bit awkward but okay this pin is
also not so nice to him
it's fight fight for the C file okay
Queenie Chu is my idea g5 I can't go g5
maybe I cannot go Queen e2 unfortunately
they have 700 looks like f7 is an issue
I've covered it but I only have very
little time zero zero zero zero six I my
god whew yeah I only noticed relatively
late that I was that I was so slow that
is not helping what is he doing you know
development for you are ok c6 is not too
bad if he gets a 10
came commerce reform might be six is a
good movement did not pay attention to
that
koalas playing in the tile arena okay
yeah I'm looking forward to that if I
flame but probably probably not yeah
blunder if I am an idiot
black was strategically already
completely outplayed down then a blunder
this one mover the only way to lose the
game I can take of us knowing that one
persona
I one time buddy Wow c6 was pretty bad
anyway so probably somewhat playable
this position yeah nice flag here it's
bullet yeah and I mean I'm not totally
slow but I mean I'm not great at bullet
but somewhat decent at least most of the
time so tragic go on now it doesn't
prevent it try to yeah make this look a
little bit stupid damn the g3 bishop
unfortunately this is very garage still
have an a5 it's there unplayable
positioning bulletin I mean if it's
really really bad you know I still try
to play somewhat decently if possible I
don't know how to win this position
looks pretty I need to go I need to
attack a3 with
I actually blundered stuff him
let's not promote that I never know what
they will do whether you would like them
huge like yeah I have huge like a shame
now unless you lost that you to like I
think most of the time mostly all of a
sudden was like I lost some seconds
without making a move yeah thanks
it's in case you're watching strong my
connection sucks you know sees don't see
that yeah I have reconnecting to listen
do look I just lost 15 something seconds
probably the storm is doing the making
the issues him I got some time back
what's going on here no and fortunately
I cannot play like that what's going on
you I think he gave me some time back
but how
I hope this this problem does not
persist when when the tournament is
tonight is taking place
I wish it before I could play okay it
was actually not so easy here not at all
oh my god ah yeah
I came yeah I wanted to I wanted to
[Music]
practice some bullet but the connection
currently is probably too bad for that
I'm going to try I mean I think I just I
should have I should lead this match
because I'm just just better here but
the the leg is pretty terrible
and I cannot play it that's impossible
hmm yeah okay I think after that I will
try if I can play let's say a little bit
of blitz at least but right if I'm
constantly losing connection is he 37
seconds for for no reason there
I don't know if the stream is actually
working at all I guess I guess I guess
it does I don't get I go I only get
minimum yeah my ping is terrible I don't
even have a ping yeah the stream is fine
[Music]
[Music]
now I'm losing on time yeah it's it's
kind of silly yeah yeah it's a it's a
bit it's a bit too bad yeah um I don't
know I don't know it's possible I mean
the storm that we have currently I'm
sorry here the storm that we have going
at the moment it's like it's pretty
tough that's pretty tough so I don't
know if from if it's a good idea to to
do this I can I mean I can try um I can
try a longer time control but what is
and now the ping is excellent again oh
okay I'm going to give it another try
going to give it another try if if it
doesn't work it doesn't work it doesn't
each five is kind of a bit move okay
very weird
I would like the night 1f form got you
regroup that and I'm blundering the
bloody thing
[Music]
I don't know here queen 27 it doesn't
work him threatening move which is six I
don't really see a move against that
what does he do now Wow okay I think now
the connection is okay again so we'll
see if this persists or if there are
issues again I'm happy with this it
looks nice against the setup Bishop c5
f5 looks strong hmm
I have a connection problem again crap
come on and it's a bit of a bit of a
shame maybe it gets better later today
because I really want to stream the
title tournament I'm kind of lucky that
I have time tonight usually I will teach
Thursday evenings but not this Thursday
evening air it's it's he's not taking at
that time already clearly better here if
not winning yeah hello to all of you in
the chit
I could have gone we should be to
earlier need your activators double
against f3 okay what makes me me after I
I'm just have clearly quicker actually
playing with I'm down one time I'm
losing this game on time which is kind
of a joke
but okay now I cannot play like that
it's not possible as well as like a
complete route to the skin and then you
lose on time so yeah I don't know I
don't think it makes any sense to be
honest I'm sorry about that I would have
liked a stream for like you bought in
how or so what the connection is just
too bad it's nothing much that I can do
if she looks like a couple of seconds
every single move and it doesn't doesn't
work yeah I don't know longer type
controls it also sucks I mean I can try
to play three plus two blitz or
something yeah thanks so messaging me
about the study me cuz if I read that
correctly I mean I I did a three plus
two what I can try but I'm not playing
if I lose like a couple of seconds every
single move that's just a bit too sick
okay so let's see our some e6000
and two seconds is actually the
increment I'm sorry that was that was
nonsense
here I'm just going to play Bishop
Bishop to d6 I don't believe he's taking
no yeah this way the games also take
ages yeah
2 2 2 Street has two streams in a row
yeah yeah and I intend to do it more
often of course today the reason is
actually that that storm that we have
because they stopped all train traffic
in my state so yeah maybe I don't know
um I don't know that of how this routing
works to Lee chess I mean the storm is
also like in Belgium Netherlands gather
Western know the eastern parts of a
France so I didn't know know that is
that steep
I know I don't think the German trains
are always on schedule they have gotten
more reliable I really think so
maybe statistics don't support that
but I think it's gotten a bit better
yeah I'm going through the e4 square
that's a good square for the night and
stopping immediate attacking ideas
playing very quickly stir in a bullet
mode f5 I've want to support my before
pawn and take next 25
yeah let's take that I can actually take
with the D pawn maybe route d1 next
you can check your peel you ping you
mean yep
you know it doesn't the ping is probably
very unsteady usually the ping is
excellent orally
so I'm preparing before him between
trade would be nice as well thinking
about Queen jf7 but he will probably not
take
Quincy d5m would be nice to have whoa
okay yeah that changes the whole game
completely
so going to switch that over to the
Kings side
you can still go here
someone is posting my feeder waiting
cart are you doing that yeah I think
that's my feeder ID at least any
anything like that any questions about
it
okay rupees six maybe out let's do it
it's a funny funny em porn configuration
I can always go look age 6 to to cover
g6
[Music]
okay that was my idea
to undermine the default pond
so it's got this chick 'i'm
how'd you do that some pressure against
the deep pond maybe moxie fire white is
okay epoxy form I'm a little bit you
know what I forgot
I completely forgot that this is
increment yeah I was thinking okay I'm
winning this on time anyhow doesn't
really matter what I play but it does
because of the increment I'm not just
winning this on time I came I think I'm
going to promote this now right there is
no direct threat these I don't see it
King is reasonably safe that's the only
one okay but I have got Queen h4 okay
then then so there's there's some there
are some issues
[Music]
back to this first yeah here queen h5
check and then promotion should be
fairly fairly easily winning hmm he
still kill his friends that okay Wow a
Queen f6 ahead huh
I had Queen f6
[Music]
a good thing about this is I'm also not
losing on time because of the because of
the increment am I doing this well I
don't think I am okay I'm up huge chunks
of material and so somehow fail to put
it away
yeah
so let's win the H pong this game is
taking ages really with the increment
and the lag involved
no probably will resign now yeah I don't
know it works kind of okay but it's a
still a little bit iffy disconnection
okay so let's go for one more game we
form a my blitz rating has really sucks
why is that so bad
did I play some bad tournaments I know
it's a bit of a bit of a bummer for the
opponents I think I'm heavily underrated
him okay so okay Knight f6 is 95 so
black here voluntarily yeah except that
the bishop stays on c8 let's aim okay so
I'm going to just go rook the one and
complete development or maybe maybe I
can go for a direct King side attack Oh
doesn't look good
the knight only five okay is strong or
was strong but it's definitely not worth
to yeah basically go for strategic
resignation giving me the the pair of
bishops just like that
the our connection is maybe a little bit
more stable now I don't I did not play
that well by the way
okay so looks nice it looks really
really nice now the bishop won't be
seven it's really it's quite terrible
that's quite terrible okay yeah let's
take with us I'm not sure I should be
partner - no I don't think so I don't I
mean if this means like subscriptions
and so on it's I don't have that but I'm
very new to this streaming f6 is it
could move actually that's pretty strong
nothing shouldn't have allowed that I've
got 100 viewers that's good yeah these
are all chess books
almost all of them yeah the interesting
thing is there is there is screen f1 all
of a sudden
okay I want to prevent that if I've is
kind of weak it's kind of weird that
this is not not better at same
yeah I want to set this up with the
possibility to subscribe and and things
like that but yeah we can also do
challenges yeah of course why not
I wanted to play em this guy again to
give him the rematch so but the game
like after that would be why not why not
play challenges yeah II five hangs
okay I've got we should be for shake
like here
[Music]
I did not really think this through
properly I really didn't
yeah up here that's true currently I'm
only executive accepting challenges from
friends this is possible I had times
where I got so many challenges that I
kind of had to stop it
I need to change the setting them but I
don't I'm not going to stream for much
longer I really need dinner at some
point okay he still has this this thing
going him queen is seven something like
that don't miss god bishop if I if at
the end this one cuz it's not it's not
enough Oh weird
still not easy for him either but
okay quick move and then see what
happens the move first think later thing
not coefficient g3 Bishop d4 would help
[Music]
so I cannot move this doesn't work
these seven is still an idea at the end
yeah I'm losing I'm losing this maybe
cannot take yeah it's just about in time
crazy it's really crazy to lose this
game because it was a and was completely
winning for sure what you defended as
well okay let's let's see I'll take some
challenges to have to quickly set this
up it's probably here somewhere
game behavior or is that privacy always
is so going back so you can challenge me
so I'm going to play some some games
playing some challenges okay let's see
what Christopher is up to I don't mind
if it's raiding ready to unknown rated
so it's really important so I've got a
bingo gambit
Jesus was a bit on the quick side I
really don't play this line but let's
see what Christopher was up to
I'm just going to castle go d6 and this
is not a really great line yeah I
screwed he says this is not much as a
reference to I played too quickly
[Music]
he's seeking a long time you long long
time I came just taking
Kate and Bishop e6 you almost always
have some kind of compensation him okay
you have to take with the night if I
kept you know
going 497 try to fight for would be five
square bishop maybe Bishop g5 I don't
know all right then I'm that I'm going
to do it cannot be that terrible
yeah rook e8 against Bishop g5 that
blunder stuff I think no I'm on D I'm
here okay so I've got a couple of
additional additional additional
challenges taking names I recognize from
the chat on twitch making playing the
Kings Indian gets a couple of good pre
moves okay white is going for but we
need style setup let's see okay trying
to go for b5 now you know it's prepared
play on the B file it's not a bad idea
wait um okay let's cover that slower
than 3.2 mm yeah not in the context of
such a stream
I mean I can do a a stream at some other
time that has some it features rapid
games but don't want to do this right
away so maybe I would like to use those
squares yeah yeah yeah that's definitely
true I think I'm going to trade one
I should not not forget that this is
actually three plus two Y naught bullet
playing a bit too quick here but too
quickly
yeah I mean three plus two is a time
where I actually end up with additional
time quite often
trying to go to c6 and a techie 3d
never know whoops why did she do that
oops there's nothing going on actually
can take here take and nothing's
what's go what's no hmm okay nothing
going on I think um yeah let's play who
is on here she's tiny yeah let's play
stylee
yeah that's the French exchange not lots
of fun for black I think I know it
sounds many weird to some people this is
actually something that I have analyzed
recently for whites um I have some vague
idea about this it sounds weird to
analyze the French exchange but
no that's subjective bishop yeah sorry
about that that was a quick one
I don't do rematches let's let's give
other people the opportunity to play
chess
toss to roll going to play maybe it's
not playing it seems
stylee says I hate the exchange French
yeah this is wife apply them in some to
some extent at least okay we have a
closed society in here so yeah maybe d4
is an option here that is interesting
interesting
no white played that now five maybe
a35 that that looked like it could give
some it could annoy black a little bit
yeah let's see what yeah you don't want
to give up that bishop so I guess Bishop
g5 or this one this is maybe actually
better okay
King oh3 now it's not bad he's taking a
long a lot of time thanks for the nice
feedback there Patrick
let's add steam Jim this is more or less
as it looks like a weird form of the
Dragon iam I'm happy about this quick
development a with Roxy aid yeah it's a
good question if I play lots of engine
users I don't know it depends on what
Lots exactly means I think there are
quite there are quite some cheaters
around there on all platforms but I
think it is less common than many people
many people think
so I'm a yeah rooks III probably doesn't
even work now
if I go 94 we should take Luke take
spontex before Queen takes before if
I've probably comes yeah that wasn't
great yeah I tried to stream frequently
but I have to see how her that also fits
into my into my schedule again today is
a little bit of a slow day with my
regular work because of the storm
there's simply I cannot get to my chest
lesson spin I was supposed to travel to
one today but I couldn't discipline no
trains chest toss drone is just plain
too slowly him
it is three plus two so you have all
kinds of all kinds of possibilities here
with the increment but Lucario's are you
training to be a Grandmaster no not no
not at this time
yeah I'm a professional chess teach and
let's say content creator sounds fancy
though I do write stuff and produce
things for chasuble that is I also
consider that writing okay let's go
grillage yeah I'm going to stream for
maybe like 10 or 15 more minutes and
then call it the day what is grillage
doing okay let's play the Dutch defense
I don't team Bishop g5 I could have
completely forgotten but I do against
that on the g6 okay how long did it take
you to become an I am pretty long pretty
long I had a I mean I had the playing
level for quite a long time but I only
got the title in 2012 so it took a
really long time
it took a long time Watson because I
didn't play tournament so I was too busy
with my work back then yeah the night
went to f7 to try to fight for them 'if
i from be five square
yeah
drinking alcohol by playing chess it's
not a good idea definitely not
yeah so I wonder does he have some
tactical idea here don't see it like
Bishop is only seven and the rook is
only seven but does not really feel like
an immediate issue
[Music]
yeah this is my channel I know there is
no donation or anything setup I this is
twitch channel was installed a long time
ago when I was just starting basically
with the videos and and back in the day
I did not set up any donations I will I
will definitely take care of that but
for the time being I'm just doing it
without a donation button or
subscriptions or whatever but I have it
I have it on the list of things to do
yeah I managed to play e5 here and I
think the position is quite okay Wow
okay
I don't know that was necessary really
maybe just see three instead I don't
know I have worked the aid
let's jump right in
that cannot be bad I mean it can be bad
but I don't think it is so what to do
now Jim I can take on B to hear that
what's the idea
yeah definitely
drunken lawyer asked if quitting smoking
helps with your chest it definite us for
a number of reasons actually
I missed 94 that's pretty strong very
strong move yo
yeah I was relaxing too much there and I
takes p2 I play too quickly
yeah I'm lost there's just a lost
position I mean okay lost it
maybe lost is strong but it's almost
lost I have to play a piece down down
taking on b2 Queen cakes with 90 f6
coming I cannot play that okay I have a
couple of I have a couple of pounds iam
unfortunately yeah yeah quitting smoking
helps with your chest first of all it's
just a good health benefit of course
which will always be okay but one thing
that also has kind of you can easily
forget that you simply don't go smoking
during the games which costs a lot of
time I always did that and it was pretty
it was pretty time-consuming and leaving
the tournament hall and yeah it really
is kind of a pain in there to do that
the whole time
oh what a bad position
he doesn't have much time but position
is really completely completely terrible
[Music]
who could take c5 even its increment
chess that's important you cannot just
do whatever and win I mean the time is
efficient a fourth ha Wow blundering the
house here and drop d1 maybe it's still
a couple of points so it's not the
easiest whenever really isn't okay
oh my god I think I'm I'm coming back
here with a vengeance
oh my god dad I was extremely lucky a
village completely completely killed me
here okay so um 17:30 I'm going to play
one more game
and yeah let's see what my opponent is
trying to do so what do we have let's
play something conservative him
you know your people read that right
that's a teammate of mine actually it
says practice for Saturday yeah we have
a blitz tournament coming up on Saturday
it's actually best in this position to
keep the tension with the move like with
most like age six a six Bishop d6 this
is actually strongest him taking us not
so great this is also I think decent
move I think I'm going to take and play
four and play for the IQ p m-- or let's
say in that's the wrong way to phrase
that play against IQ people okay this is
a tempo so I'm taking taking this
if he trades I have Queen III Bishop at
four so it's pretty pretty neat yeah
that's a comfortable position black it's
suffering a bit here with them with a
six but what's it what is he doing now
Queen d7 Queen e2 is awkward she cannot
move it really bishop CA does like him
no good that you played very okay I mean
I was just lost in this game he's asking
how he played so I'm going to win going
to win the pawn and probably a second
pawn yeah I wonder maybe he can move the
bishop actually let's see five I cannot
play I can then the easy move especially
three
okay I cannot keep it all okay I tried
to play it in a way that at least he
settled with an e pawn the check doesn't
matter have Queen everyone
yeah this is a pretty awful ending sorry
cannot he has a redo to show this is
hanging rock d7 yeah and this is also
something you don't want to see on the
board okay let's freeze everything here
no pawn can move the rook cannot move
okay that's the second pawn it was I was
not that was not a tenable position
may I probably take him threatening
Bishop g5 Andrew p7 winning the bishop
yeah yeah that wasn't a really good
opening result-type okay so I think I'm
going for one more game
one more game what about a leeches
master here Flynn oh one more game what
is that she zero okay he plays a Spanish
I think
yeah there's an interesting line it's a
bit more yeah a bit more complicated
than some of the main lines so why is it
that I cannot take a form I will take it
I will take it as mentioned more than
once the centre Pond I will almost
always take I don't really see anything
terrible going on
we ate and what about this I can't take
yeah I ignored that possibility but it
is strong just grab a stream okay
I'm two points up time for the end game
yep
yeah I know it's opposite colored
bishops but my bishop is also better
than his bishop
that's a fairly strong case I mean it's
a case where two points really mean
something in the opposite colored
business ending of this
so slowly
I don't know that move that that book
backwards and I know that this this book
logical chess move by move it so it's
some sort of classic it's oftentimes
recommended in u.s. chess circles but
it's it's all a book that I I know so I
cannot really tell you what I think of
it I am two pawns up did I miss count
I think I'm two paws up
yeah taking two pawns was too much no
thanks I have to quit them quit the
stream now it's time for me to get
something I get something to eat okay
guys I hope you enjoyed in the stream I
[Music]
hope you enjoyed the stream I think um
we'll see each other in roughly four and
a half hours when I'm going to go for
the stream of the titled the titled
tournament so make sure that you join
then thanks a lot for watching I'll be
back soon bye bye